[Music]
growing up we were taught no matter who
you are or where you were born you could
make it in america for many americans
that means having a house a yard a
couple of kids and some money in the
bank for vacations in retirement but it
doesn't come for free it takes hard work
a lot of it
we call that the american dream
it's the reason so many people want to
come here and there is a chance that
being american and having an idea a
business or a special talent with a
little luck you can make it really big
you can have a better life than your
parents
and your children will have a better
life than you
but according to john stewart
that american dream is dead
the literal interpretation of the
american dream is that is it doesn't
matter where you were born or how you
were born or who you are that in this
country you can
rise up and go beyond that and it turns
out to be a fallacy there has always
been
a redistribution of power to the white
elite
there's so many things wrong and
misguided about that statement that
we're going to need some time to pick
that apart
but this isn't just the opinion of jon
stewart
this is a belief that is held by most
liberal leaders in america today
hillary clinton echoed this very idea
today
at an event with al sharpton who
ironically is a very powerful black
elite
the color of a person's skin still
influences who gets ahead in america and
who goes how far and who gets left
behind and that is absolutely a fact
that nobody with all their rhetoric
could in any way deny
not only is this sad but it's not an
honest assessment of the average
american success story
race is not the primary factor in
getting ahead in the united states
education work ethic
class connections geography your family
dynamic all play major roles in shaping
who gets ahead
the most important ingredient
right here
and right here
but the worst part about stewart and
clinton's commentary is that it
designates certain americans victims and
sentences them to a life without free
will
it dehumanizes them and doesn't square
with the reality of the american
experience
and in a sneaky way
makes an excuse for the failings of
democrat policies that have hurt
americans for decades
here are the facts
these are the most recent numbers from
the census
showing median household incomes in the
united states
indian americans are at the top
averaging 120 grand a year
whites are in the middle of the pack and
blacks are at the bottom
is this the picture of racial oppression
that hillary and stewart are painting
racial minorities some even first
generation immigrants like filipinos
japanese chinese and pakistani americans
making thousands and thousands of
dollars more
than the average white american
so why are black americans making less
than other people of color well that's a
very serious question that our guests
coming up will be able to answer as
they've studied that for years but our
question tonight is if the democrat
party is the home of black americans has
the democrat party failed them
and is racism just an excuse for the
democrats failure
democrats still run out in front of the
camera every week to brag about
everything they do for the black
community
what exactly is it that they're doing
and is it working
democrats put the first black woman on
the supreme court and that's a big
milestone that we can all appreciate
but democrats also blocked who would
have been the first black woman on the
supreme court janice rogers brown when
bush tried to elevate her because she
was a republican
so their intentions aren't pure
when kamala harris was asked
about this newly minted justice jackson
today she said this
you know there's so much about what's
happening in the world now
that is presenting some of the worst
of
this moment and human
behaviors and then we have a moment like
this
that i think reminds us that there is
still so much yet to accomplish and that
we can accomplish
including a day like today that is so
historic and so important for so many
reasons
biden could have nominated any liberal
justice for the high court who would
rule the exact same way jackson would
but this is historic because she's a
black woman which is largely symbolic
worthy but symbolic
and that's all part of the plan
democrats will promise they'll save your
community protect you educate you enrich
you
but do they
i'm not so sure
but they sure are big on symbolism
what have democrats delivered to black
americans on issues like school choice
safe streets and wages
they've done a lot of kneeling
but where's police reform
the patronage mill is in full swing
though and so is the pandering
i remember visiting you al
when you got transferred to brooklyn the
one thing you wanted was fried chicken
and
we got that delivered i think that may
have been the last fried chicken you ate
though if you have a problem figuring
out whether you're for me or trump and
you ain't black
what's something that you always carry
with you hot sauce
really yeah yeah really i want you to
know people are going to see this and
say okay she's pandering to black people
okay
is it working
i guess it is working
but for how much longer
the one guy who presided over
significant change was called racist by
democrats every day
donald trump unleashed the economy
resulting in record low black poverty
rates record low black unemployment and
huge income gains for black americans
pre-covet
not to mention authorizing hundreds of
millions of dollars to historically
black colleges something the democrats
didn't get done
but democrats you see they yell louder
and they yell scarier stuff like if you
don't vote for us republicans are going
to put you back in chains
he's going to let the big banks once
again write their own rules
wall street
they're going to put you all back in
chains
is racism holding you back or are
democrats
white politicians who talk about fried
chicken and hot sauce
then say you're not black if you don't
vote for them that's messed up
and if you get ahead they want credit
no you deserve the credit
the american dream is very much alive
for everyone
just ask these people
i think the american dream is is is
easier than ever before it's just you
got to work at it i think i'm the
american dream barack knows the american
dream because he's lived it surely
we can give
everyone in this country a fair chance
at that great american dream america
creates an atmosphere for people to
achieve so the american dream is just
the ability to achieve anybody can
attain it
so when you see white democrat
politicians like hillary or wealthy
liberal comedians like jon stewart tell
you the american dream is dead and your
skin color determines how far you can go
in this country
when you know in your heart your own
potential is huge
and see these success stories all around
you
take a second and think
why don't they believe you can make it
and that answer will tell you everything
you need to know about the system
they think they run hey sean hannity
here hey click here to subscribe to fox
news youtube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else